c'est plutôt que vous avez quitté le Pays de Galles pour étudier
la musique classique à Londres quelle était votre
ambition d'aller à New York et d'obtenir gloire
et fortune
quels étaient vos liens avec le
mouvement Fluxus avant de partir pour les
états J'ai organisé le festival ou la
musique Fluxus dans mon collège avant  ils m'ont
chassé de l'université,
je pense que le mouvement Fluxus a
quelque chose à voir avec cela, ce qui vous a fait
quitter sati pour le rock and roll,
eh bien, j'avais lu un peu et
j'étais intéressé par la prise de risques et Lou
m'a présenté un  tout un autre monde de
prise de risque te souviens-tu de la première
fois que tu as rencontré Lou Reed ouais je
faisais du café avec le
robinet d'eau chaude dans l'évier de la maison de
disques te souviens-tu quand Andy est
venu voir The Velvet  subi le bazar du café
oui je me souviens qu'il y avait tout un
entourage qui a défilé au milieu
du plateau et on était sur le point de se faire virer
et donc c'était la dernière fois qu'on
y jouait et docteur on s'est fait virer les
choses se sont beaucoup éclaircies quand  il a
produit le premier album des Stooges vous êtes-vous
comporté comme Andy produisant The Velvet
Je pense que les Stooges ont été découverts ouais
ils n'avaient vraiment pas besoin de beaucoup de direction
et c'était juste une question d'appuyer sur
le bouton d'enregistrement et de dire merci
beaucoup qu'avez-vous fait  Je pense bien à Andy en tant
que peintre quand je suis allé à
l'usine pour la première fois, j'ai découvert que cela ne s'appelait pas
une usine pour rien, il y avait des
gens qui travaillaient très très dur tout
le temps et je n'avais jamais été capable de
mettre en place dans mon  dans mon esprit quel genre de
qualités je recherchais dans
l'art contemporain comme on le trouve chez les
maîtres anciens qui semblaient avoir beaucoup de
travail en détail et avec Andy c'était la
couleur c'était la variété la
simplicité des couleurs dans le  comment ils
étaient très surprenants et très clairs pourquoi
pensez-vous que Velvets est devenu un tel
culte probablement parce que nous parlions
de choses très difficiles c'était
probablement un esprit là-bas auquel les gens
s'identifiaient vraiment je ne suis pas
objecti  ai assez pour en parler
et aussi que nous pourrions être considérés comme des
échecs parce que je veux dire que nous pourrions être
considérés comme des succès parce que nous étions des
échecs et nous avons vécu nos échecs avec
le grand style qu'en pensez-vous The
Velvet split Je pense que cela a probablement commencé
quand Lou a dit  Andy, il ne voulait pas le faire
courir et les choses ont empiré à
partir de là, car nous n'avions personne
là-bas qui était vraiment un conspirateur avec
nous et il était toujours là pour nous rappeler
toutes les idées folles que nous avions et que
nous devrions  continuer avec eux quand j'ai besoin de
partir, il n'y avait personne là-bas sur qui nous
pouvions faire rebondir nos idées et nous
avons fini par être un groupe de route, ce qui est
très douloureux, je pense que toutes ces idées
que nous avions se sont en quelque sorte évanouies dans
les airs LuAnn  vous auriez pu être comme
Lennon McCartney Jagger Richards ou
Rodgers et Hart êtes-vous d'accord avec
cette idée très flatteuse vous
restez toujours en contact avec Sterling Morrison et
Moe Tucker oui je les vois je ne leur ai pas parlé
à tous ouais je e  J'apprécie
beaucoup le style de conversation Sterling et Sterling et cela
me manque ce
que font Sterling et Moe que
nous sommes toujours diplômés est maintenant dr.
sterling Morrison et Marina ont
enregistré et fait beaucoup de tournées comme
vous le savez et
je pense qu'une fois sterling qui veut
s'intéresser à nouveau à la guitare, il
n'a jamais abandonné mais je veux dire que c'est toujours
là et il je pense qu'il souhaite qu'il
y ait  quelque part où il pourrait accrocher
son chapeau quand avez-vous vu Andy pour la
dernière fois, je pense que nous parlions
de faire un exercice avec lui le
matin,
il avait une personne qui est venue et a fait
un exercice individuel et nous avons commencé
discutant d'une vidéo d'exercice d'Andy Warhol
avec de la musique puis je suis parti en tournée
j'ai entendu la mauvaise nouvelle quand j'étais peu
en tournée quand avez-vous vu Nikko pour la dernière fois
c'était à Bruxelles lors d'un concert nous venons de
voyager à travers le Japon
elle était avec un  groupe a joué ensemble
dans la partie du bazar en
affaires quand vous avez rencontré Lou au doigt d'Andy
depuis combien de temps l'avez-vous vu je l'avais vu
souvent pendant assez longtemps pendant toutes
ces années mais il n'avait jamais vraiment
discuté de quoi que ce soit  de valeur sauf  t
découvrir ce qui est arrivé aux redevances du Velvet
Underground que nous avons finalement
découvert comment avez-vous réussi à retravailler
avec Lou Reed après si longtemps,
c'était très excitant, je veux dire
que nous savions tous les deux que nous avions
beaucoup  beaucoup de terrain à rattraper et j'étais
vraiment intéressé à former à
nouveau un partenariat, il était très important
pour moi de voir si l'énergie et l'
agressivité étaient toujours là et c'était
et c'était très excitant et gratifiant